what is up everybody it's animac here
for anime uproar and deku's spectacular
return to the UA Battlefield has
completely changed the game in Boku no
hero but Deku has just had to face the
terrible Truth for the very first time
bakugou is technically dead although
headshot is trying to revive him the
other heroes are also severely injured
and on the brink of death and shigaraki
just keeps getting stronger as he
unleashes his final form upon the world
deku's heroic rage vs shigaraki's
vicious destruction are clashing and the
fate of the entire world is at stake so
let's get into it you guys know how this
works if you enjoy our videos you want
to see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment it only takes you a
second but it really helps us with that
YouTube algorithm and if you're new to
the channel or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications finally this video will of
course contain any manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned okay so in the previous
chapter Deku finally returned to the UA
building and to the center stage of the
story with his epic green Japanese
Spider-Man entrance but it wasn't all
good news for the heroes because
shigaraki had also just unlocked a brand
new power his mutations evolved further
still transforming his body into its
optimal form and so the chapter Ended as
shigaraki in his final form also known
as the Apex Legend shikaraki form came
face to face with Deku and an epic Clash
ensued the latest chapter starts off
with a quick flashback explaining how
Deku was able to return to the UA so
quickly as I mentioned in my last video
Deku had spotted multiple objects flying
towards him back at the end of chapter
357 but it was never revealed to us what
those objects actually were then in the
previous chapter as Deku made his epic
return we saw that Jets from stars and
stripes's Squadron flying in the sky
above Deku chapter 367 confirms that the
objects that had approached Deku back in
chapter 357 were in fact members of the
Stars and Stripes Squadron members who
disobeyed direct orders to leave Japan
and instead they decided to stay here
and help fight the villains in any way
that they could that is a pretty big
deal since these are members of the
American armed forces who decided to go
Rogue in order to help fight in another
country something like that would be
massive news if it ever happened here in
our own world but in a world with
superheroes and super villains it's just
like a passing side note Deku had used
black whip to grab onto one of the Jets
and he was pulled back to UA much faster
than he would have been able to arrive
otherwise I for one am glad that this
happened because at this crucial stage
of the story the Final Act of the story
having Deku not playing any sort of
important role for six months in real
time just doesn't seem right to me like
we had three major battles going on at
the same time with the fate of all of
Japan and the world at stake I guess
four battles if you want to count okuto
Island although I don't think we should
count dokudo Island and yet Deku the
main character was stuck flying out
there somewhere off the coast of Japan
and he was unable to contribute to any
of the battles but Deku is finally back
now and after getting a pep talk from
the Squadron Pilots about the need for
Deku to honor the memory of stars and
stripes by taking down the greatest
villain to ever live we are taken back
to the present where Deku is already
engaging in battle against Apex Legend
the shigaraki Deku manages to land a
blow on shigaraki and the villain can
already tell the Deku seems stronger
than he was before Deku has definitely
gotten stronger since he last faced
shigaraki injaku and he has unlocked new
quirks we can assume that he has
unlocked all of his quirks by now
although we still haven't seen him use
the second one for all users Quirk so we
don't know what it is yet that said the
all-for-one personality within shigaraki
does recognize that Deku is now using
fajin the third one for all users Quirk
which he has personal experience with
from back when the third user was still
alive thanks to his ability to
effectively use fajin and other quirks
in tandem Deku is able to actually push
shigaraki back long enough for him to
survey the situation on the battlefield
Deku apologizes for being late and asks
if everyone is okay but what he sees
next absolutely crushes him all the main
Heroes who were fighting on this
battlefield are severely injured or on
the verge of death bakugo technically is
dead at least clinically speaking and
Deku even notices his all might hero
card on the ground beside his body Deku
is absolutely destroyed by this and
that's not even close to being all the
bad news that he's going to get genus is
on his knees and barely moving miruko is
literally torn apart and unconscious Sun
eater and nejire are also severely
injured and unconscious and to make
things is even worse this is the exact
moment in which shigaraki sash roll for
one decides to taunt Deku he reminds
Deku that Deku was too late for the
party implying that if Deku had been
here earlier he could have saved
everyone and he could have prevented
this tragedy from happening faced with
this taunting and the cruel truth about
the situation on the battlefield Deku
begins to lose control of his emotions
and so his body and his Quirk begin to
morph into a vicious Berserker form that
threatens to spiral out of control and
this by the way is exactly what all for
one slash shigaraki is hoping for he
wants Deku to be blinded by rage he
wants Deku to start making Hasty and
Reckless decisions and he wants to take
advantage of these Reckless decisions to
break deku's spine and put him out of
commission for good as we all know by
now all for one loves to engage in
psychological warfare he loves to psych
his opponents out which leads to the
opponents losing their cool and making
mistakes and is exactly what he's hoping
is going to happen to Deku we saw
something similar happening to Endeavor
a few chapters ago when he lost his cool
and made a hasty move but thankfully
Meteo is still conscious and after last
week's peachy super move he jumps in
with yet another overpowered super move
in fact this is one of the most
overpowered super moves in the history
of anime manga talk no Jutsu Meteo tells
Deku that it's all right he knows
exactly how Deku feels and he also feels
terrible about the fact that he wasn't
able to do more to protect everyone who
got her but meteor also tells daku that
the situation is not as bad as it looks
despite being severely injured all the
heroes on the battlefield are still
alive they are all still breathing and
although bakugou is technically dead Ed
shot is currently working to revive him
from the inside Meteo says that he's
sure Ed shot will succeed so even though
they've suffered some losses none of
these losses are actually permanent
everyone can and still make it out a lot
the important thing that Deku has to
remember now is that all for one wants
him to lose his cool and make a stupid
mistake so Deku has to overcome his rage
and keep his emotions in check there is
still hope so Deku can't give up he has
to keep his wits about him and he has to
fight smart all for one slash shigaraki
says that this is naive idealism and
it's nothing but a silly fantasy but
Meteo screams that if anyone can turn
fantasy into reality it's the heroes and
they are heroes these words remind Deku
of the lessons that all might and the
previous users of one for all had taught
him he is also reminded of the members
of stars and stripes Squadron who
disobeyed orders because they believed
in him and with all that he manages to
regain control of his emotions now
backed up by the quirks of all the
former one for all users at least the
ones who had a quirk Deku raps black
whip around his face like a scarf he
then stares at the villain with a fierce
look in his eyes and he addresses all
for one directly Deku asks all for one
is shigaraki still there and that is how
this chapter ends and this was big we
were all wondering how Deku would react
once he saw the Carnage on this
battlefield and we knew that he would
blame himself for everything that
happened that's because he was supposed
to be here on the UA Battlefield and he
was supposed to be backing everyone else
up the fact that he slipped up and got
himself teleported to the wrong location
is going to eat him up on the inside and
many of us were speculating that when he
sees bakugou's seemingly dead body Deku
might snap and the raw power of all for
one and all its quirks could consume him
this would be a disaster because it
could lead Deku to make bad decisions
which would leave him open to a deadly
attack from shigaraki like just imagine
if Deku went nuts and started destroying
everything around him and the collateral
damage resulted in monoma losing sight
of shigaraki that Split Second mistake
would allow shigaraki to use all his
quirks again to regenerate his entire
body and then everything the heroes did
up to this point would have been for
nothing that said I am still convinced
that something like this will happen
eventually yes Meteo was able to calm
Deku down for now and yes bakugou will
almost certainly survive but if
something else happens during this fight
like if one of the big three is killed
or some other UA student the Deku is
close to his killed Deku may still snap
and gold berserk he has a lot of power
within him now and unless he can control
his emotions perfectly that power will
threaten to consume him and in such a
stressful battle to the death situation
such as this one controlling your
emotions perfectly is almost impossible
and I mean from a storytelling
perspective let's be real we all want to
see shigaraki at full power with the
full use of all his quirks going up
against Deku at full power and with all
of his quirks unlocked so I do think
that some something will happen that
will break monoma's Erasure and allow
shigaraki to reach his full potential at
some point in the future if shigaraki
can figure out a way to get to izawa he
might be able to kill two birds with one
stone he will stop the Erasure at least
eventually and at the same time he will
enrage Deku leading to him losing
control and acting recklessly at that
point even deku's final Quirk whatever
it turns out to be may not be enough to
stop shigaraki in his Apex Legend form
and with all his quirks fully functional
including super regeneration that is
when I believe that all of deku's quirks
will suddenly merge into one single
ultimate Quirk Deku will reach Quirk
Singularity and his body will then also
evolve in a somewhat similar way to
shigaraki it won't be exactly the same
as shigaraki because he had all those
ujiko modifications and Deku simply
didn't but at the same time Deku has
less quirks than all of all for one's
stolen works so we'll see how it goes we
will then see the greatest single clash
in the history of mha as full power
final form shigaraki goes up against
full power Quirk Singularity Deku and
that is going to be absolutely epic that
at least is my theory for how this whole
thing will ultimately end but let me
know what your theories are down below
my biggest worry is that Deku is going
to try too hard to save tanko shimura
who is hiding somewhere within shigaraki
something that this latest chapter even
hinted at and I believe that this could
lead to some sort of anticlimactic talk
no Jutsu ending or it could lead to Deku
making the mistake of going easy on
shigaraki and getting someone else
killed as a result what do you guys
think will any major character actually
die by the end of the manga and if so
who will it be will it be izawa almight
Endeavor shigaraki monoma it better not
be Medio or miruko that's all I'm saying
if you guys enjoy enjoyed this Boku no
hero video and you want to see more in
the future leave a quick like and
comment right now it really helps me out
with that YouTube algorithm and if you
haven't already please take the time to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications it is a
completely free but very important way
of supporting the channel here on
YouTube you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
big thank you to all of our anime outpro
patrons for making videos like this one
possible special thank you to trucker
Tim a disciple of Lord twigo himself and
I can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons including Alpha Sigma but they
hefa The Toasted Chi Cory McGowan own
Taylor and Anime s code M finally thank
you to all of our other patrons
including Pro Hero tier patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh on Hell Cruise Alicia
actor Fatboy games kaido might be a duck
alivenia Sandy and the school bus if you
enjoy our videos and you feel that they
provide value to you consider supporting
us on patreon or by becoming a channel
member as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys